when it comes to gun safety in America
we all have to agree whatever your view
is that we have too much gun violence
that we are alone in human in humanity
for the level of violence we have in our
own communities this is not a war zone
but we have 90 people dying from gun
violence virtually every day with
certain populations even more evident
young african-american men is the
leading cause of death we have a
Virginia Tech every day in terms of just
the number of people who succumb to
murder and and that type of related gun
violence and so I don't care who you are
as American that's this is an
unacceptable reality and for us to have
built a level of tolerance of this is to
me I disappointing is not even a the
right word it is deeply frustrating and
painful that we as a society would
tolerate this now that said there are
obviously strong emotions where people
believe its second Amendment rights to
own guns where people who are sports men
and women believed to need to uncommon
and there are people out there who have
guns because they fear for their lives
and believe they should have a right to
defend themselves I am one of those
people that believes that we can respect
those three groups people were striding
on the Second Amendment people who
believe that they need weapons to
protect themselves and people who are
sports especially people were in it for
the sport that we can do common-sense
gun-safety things that can make us all
safety including people who have guns
and I know that this is not a minority
opinion that I have because when we pull
gun owners the overall majority 60 70
sometimes eighty percent agree with
common-sense steps that we could take
for gun safety so there are loopholes
that need to be closed that I think most
people would agree right now we have a
situation where if you abuse your spouse
and have been charged to convicted of
that you can't buy a weapon well there's
a loophole it involves if it's not your
spouse but your boyfriend we need
close that domestic violence happens too
often in our country and there's ways we
know to protect that and states that
have been more aggressive have seen
violence against women using guns drop
we have the data that shows it and this
is a simple common-sense thing that we
need to do that again most Americans
agree on we should not have a country
where you are suspected of terrorism and
you can easily buy a gun we should have
common sense background checks and if
that background check takes longer than
24 hours so be it because the overall
majority have instant checks so if
because there's such a realm of common
sense things that don't infringe those
groups i mentioned earlier the question
is is why aren't we doing them and and
and that's something that I believe is
reflective of all of us and our sense of
urgency and demand is not what it needs
to be to get Congress to move and and we
should we should understand that so much
better as possible and I'm a big
believer that better is possible even
good is not enough and what we have
right now with the level of violence is
not good it's deplorable so my hope is
is that that we can just find that
common ground that common-sense reality
do the things that are going to protect
ourselves remember what happened in
Paris many of those people could have
come to our country without a visa
they're in the visa waiver program
foreign nationals on our soil could have
walked into a gun shop or a gun show
loaded up a trunk full of weapons and
done the same kind of carnage or worse
here because of our lacks gun laws now I
don't know many Americans that believe
that foreign nationals on our soil
should be able to buy weapons so easily
without common-sense checks and the like
and and and so for all of us who believe
in that we should be doing something
about it because I fear that the these
mass shootings make it worse that will
have more bloodshed and more violence
until we come around to the
understanding that we should be doing
the common-sense gun safety things that
can make us all safer
you